good morning to you this is sky news
breakfast it is seven o'clock in the uk
nine o'clock here in kiev as russian
troops continue to advance towards this
city
no let up russia launches airstrikes
overnight on a military base on the edge
of the capital here
bearing down on kiev's satellite images
show a russian military convoys
stretching for 40 miles nearing this
city
[Music]
the international criminal court to
investigate alleged war crimes in
ukraine as president zielenski says
russian troops are intensifying the
shelling
in new york an unprecedented meeting of
the un general assembly to discuss a
resolution condemning moscow's
aggression
a growing refugee crisis as more than
half a million people flee ukraine a
diplomatic dash boris johnson heads to
poland and estonia warning vladimir
putin he'll feel the consequences for
this invasion
[Music]
increasingly isolated fifa gives russia
the boot as more organizations turn
their backs on russia
we'll have the latest throughout the
morning from here in the capital as
russia's invasion of ukraine enters a
sixth day
[Music]
good morning a russian convoy stretching
about 40 miles is closing in on kiev
president putin has shown no sign of
stopping the invasion of ukraine despite
unprecedented sanctions and growing
international isolation and this morning
reports from a regional governor of the
deaths of 70 ukrainian servicemen in
russian shelling in the east of the
country
these are the key developments today the
chief prosecutor of the international
criminal court plans to open an
investigation into possible war crimes
and crimes against humanity here
the united nations high commissioner for
refugees has reported at least 102
civilian deaths including seven children
the true number could be much higher
the un says more than half a million
refugees have now fled ukraine for
neighboring countries
ukraine's foreign minister says the
united states has offered more support
for his country in the form of sanctions
and weapons first this morning diana
magnay has this report from moscow
a russian airstrike on a military base
at bravery northeast of the ukrainian
capital kiev drive quickly as they'll
strike again the man says as flames
light up the horizon
the russians are closing in on the
capital these are the latest satellite
images showing a huge convoy almost 40
miles long moving south towards kiev the
convoy's tip just 15 miles from the
center
and here just to the west of the capital
the devastation from the weekend's fight
a bridge in the town of bucha blown up
we're not sure by who and total
destruction on the streets
peace talks on monday saw very little
progress beyond a call to meet again and
with russian helicopters pictured here
positioned at the ready in belarus
ukraine's president called for the west
to impose a no-fly zone over his country
evil armed with missiles bombs artillery
must be stopped immediately
to destroy economically to show that
humanity is able to defend itself i
believe that the complete closure of the
sky for russian missiles planes and
helicopters should be considered
in kharkiv close to the russian border
evidence of the use of banned cluster
bombs shells which explode to release
numerous little bombers which scatter
across a wider area
russia appears to be ramping up its
onslaught on ukraine with a resistance
tougher than it may have bargained for
at a cost no doubt of more destruction
to this sovereign land and its civilians
the international criminal court says it
plans to open an investigation into
potential war crimes carried out by
russia in ukraine leading up to and
including the invasion
neither russia nor ukraine are
signatories to the icc but ukraine has
accepted the jurisdiction of the court
which means the chief prosecutor can
move forward
this says president zielinski signed a
document on monday requesting immediate
accession to the eu
an understandable course of action for
him
red rag to a bull for vladimir putin
diana magne sky news moscow
and we'll talk to diana in just a moment
there's just been an update from the
ministry of defense in london who do
these intelligence
updates and they're saying that the
russian advance on kiev has made little
progress over the past 24 hours probably
as a result of continuing logistical
difficulties
russian forces uh they say have
increased their use of artillery north
of kiev and in vicinities of kharkiv and
chernahiv the use of heavy artillery is
dense in densely populated urban areas
greatly increases the risks as the mod
of civilian casualties
russia has failed to gain this is
interesting gain control of the air
space over ukraine uh prompting a shift
to knight operations in an attempt to
reduce
their losses that from the ministry of
defence in london let's join diana now
who is in
moscow and diana is the sense
now that
vladimir putin is going to prosecute
this invasion prosecute this war to the
end
well i think that we haven't seen the
full force of what russia could bring in
and we haven't seen the kind of strategy
that they've used in previous wars and
that may be for a number of reasons that
may be because the kremlin completely
miscalculated uh the kind of response
they would get they miscalculated the
kind of resistance they thought perhaps
that the ukrainians would be more
pleased to see them perhaps they believe
their own
peacekeeping liberating narrative but
that has certainly not played out in the
way they expected on these first uh five
days and here we are on day six and
we're beginning to see uh much heavier
shelling
perhaps we will see more deployment of
the air force because i was interested
that the ministry of defense said they
failed to gain control of the airspace
i'm not sure that russia has really uh
put its um full force of its air power
into operation but if you think back to
their um intervention in syria we saw
sustained
russian air strikes of syrian cities
which were indiscriminate caused huge
civilian loss of life i think we may
begin to see
that kind of strategy take place in
ukraine too and perhaps it was because
they still wanted to sell to their own
people the narrative that they were
going in as um liberators as defenders
that they didn't go in as hard as they
might but i think given the fact that uh
vladimir putin may see now that his
initial tactics haven't worse worked he
may go in for a much bloodier campaign
and of course there are belarusian
troops lined up along that
southern border of belarus northern
border of ukraine close to kiev
who could be deployed at any moment they
haven't been sent in yet but they might
and i think
this is possibly just the beginning and
we haven't seen the worst of it yet we
did hear overnight from um the regional
governor of a town quite near to kharkiv
um near sumi also where we've seen some
vigorous fighting
that 70 ukrainian servicemen had been
killed a huge loss of life and the
ukrainian parliament today tweeted uh
eternal glory to the heroes of ukraine
and in my report i talked about the fact
that zelensky has president zielinski
has asked for eu accession he's also
asked for there to be a no-fly zone over
the skies of ukraine
i wonder whether the eu will um do what
will definitely be a very very uh
provocative move um for vladimir putin
and the u.s has already said that they
don't want to implement a no-fly zone or
that they're very cautious about it
because they don't want to deploy u.s
troops to implement it and put
themselves in a situation where you have
the u.s facing off against russian
troops because that could escalate
things further and that i think is the
real danger for the west as they pour
more and more supply weapons into uh
kiev and into ukraine to make sure that
this does not escalate into a war of
nato against russia
because that could make things even
worse than they already are
right and on sanctions um tough
sanctions now swinging sanctions
any sign at all that that is gonna deter
or dissuade
putin from what he wants to do
not from his rhetoric um yesterday he
called an emergency economic meeting to
discuss the sanctions and railed against
the west who he called the empire of
lies
and the sanctions are coming in thick
and fast japan today sanctioned
all of the top administration including
vladimir putin
i think that he did not anticipate such
a united response despite the fact he
was told over and over again that should
he invade ukraine the west would come
down with very very strong sanctions i
imagine he did not anticipate that the
central bank of russia would be
would have its assets frozen because it
has huge foreign currency reserves held
abroad and the u.s has frozen them other
countries are expected to follow suit
that means that it will be very
difficult for the central bank to sell
off those reserves and prop up the ruble
we saw the ruble lose 32 at one point in
yesterday's trade it's now back a bit i
think this is just the beginning when
you talk to economists here when you
also talk to people here uh who are
against this war and that's not
everybody but there are a large
substantial chunk of people who are
against it they feel that this is going
to set the russian people back decades
that they are going to be 20 years
behind the rest of the world as they
don't have the parts that they need for
technologies
for aeroplanes for smartphones for
tablets for games
they won't be able to pay for imported
goods because prices will go up
substantially inflation will go up you
know they've had currency shocks before
back in the 90s and i think people are
very scared that they are going to see
something like that coming soon the
question is what impact will that have
for vladimir putin will it consolidate
the regime will it uproot the regime and
although there are a lot of theories
about what might happen i think it's
really impossible to say
i think it is diana thank you very much
for that well let's take a closer look
at how
this situation in ukraine has developed
well blasts and gunfire were heard here
in the capital in bravery on the
outskirts of the city an airstrike left
a military air base on fire
there were also reports of russian
forces shelling ukraine's second
largest city kharkiv some hitting
residential areas
as for this morning there are reports
that more than 70 ukrainian soldiers as
diana was saying have been killed after
russian artillery hit a military base
around 60 miles away
in the city of otriac that's according
to the region's governor
videos have been released showing damage
to the northern city of chernhiv
ukraine's emergency ministry claims
shelling hit a residential building
there a market building a kindergarten
and to marry a pole in the south a port
city and a major russian target
president zelinski has said it is still
hanging on and it is still under
ukrainian control skies alex rossi joins
me now from dinipro in southeastern
ukraine good morning alex and i mean the
reports from kharkiv and
and other areas in the east suggest
that there is intense shelling and
intense bombing going on there
i think that's right mark it has been a
grim morning here in dunipro people have
been waking up to the sound of air raid
sirens they've stopped now
but it saw them running really for cover
in the bomb shelters there don't appear
to have been any strikes here but there
is a sense we are kind of in the central
eastern part of the country on the
dinipro river there is a sense that the
war is coming very close to here but the
focus of those attacks at the moment
seems to be
in terms of where i am on that eastern
second city of kharkiv
absolutely atrocious stories coming out
of there
overnight and from yesterday human
rights watch says it's almost certain
that uh cluster munitions have been used
indiscriminately on residential areas
now according to the mayor of kharkiv at
least nine civilians
uh have been killed uh more than 40 have
been injured but of course that number
could rise
um it could rise a lot because people
can't get into those areas
at the moment i think the more worrying
sign though is that this is perhaps a
signal that vladimir putin
is changing the tempo of this military
invasion now anybody who has seen
russian wars over the last
um 15 years will be
extremely concerned i've seen for my own
eyes what the russian air force uh has
done in aleppo and syria
mass bombing of civilian areas
terrorizing those areas to try and uh
break the will of the people i've also
seen uh what russian forces did in
grozny uh in chechnya uh they literally
kind of leveled uh cities so
that's the big fear and we are seeing
more use of artillery now more use of
rocket fire
and
we're seeing the ensuing loss of
civilian lives as well now president
zielenski is calling uh for the
international community to galvanize and
organize a tribunal of what he says are
very clear russian uh war crimes we wait
to see what happens uh with that but
certainly the the the resistance from
the ukrainians uh that still remains
extremely fierce and extremely strong
we've driven south out of here uh we've
seen them digging in for
you know what will be a very big fight
when the russian armor comes up uh from
the south in terms of the south the
target you mentioned there of mariopol
well i think the the the net of force is
closing round that my contacts there are
telling me uh that the city is pretty
much um surrounded there's been quite
heavy shelling this sounds of small arms
fire uh as well in the city and then i
think what you will see is columns of
armor moving up from the south when the
russians
believe that they control that there
will of course be ukrainian resistance
behind
those lines
and pushing from donetsk as well
to where we are to try and gain this
sort of central area of the eastern part
of the country but you know people here
are very worried and very scared about
where this is going
yeah and alex we were in kharkiv
broadcasting
last week and
you know speaking to the people there
they said they would not accept russian
control they wouldn't accept
russian troops in their city and they
wouldn't accept putin determining you
know how they lived is is that kind of
spirit still there or is
do you get a sense the resolve is is
weakening with every missile that comes
in
no i think that that strength is very
much still there people are coming into
this country to fight against the
russians large numbers of people have
left uh older people uh women children
about half a million so far but that
number's rising uh rapidly but the
resolve of the ukrainians is absolutely
immense and i think it's quite clear uh
from their tactics that they haven't
tried to defend open airs of open areas
of countryside because quite honestly
against the sheer
power and mass of russian armor that
would be an impossible task but they are
digging in i mean in lots and lots of
towns between here and mariopol i have
seen them moving into areas i won't go
into too much detail for obvious reasons
but moving into areas which could
see this descend very quickly
into a guerrilla
battle the other thing that's very
interesting as well we've now seen
quite a few videos
that have been put out not all of them
of course have been verified these are
of captured russian
soldiers these are phone messages that
they've left where they believe you know
these are young kids these are
conscripts who believed that they were
coming in here in a a glorious mission
of peacekeeping now they haven't been
coming here as peacekeepers we know that
and they've certainly been disabused of
that view being met by anti-tank weapons
by being met by uh artillery
civilians standing in the way of columns
of of armor so i think if the ukrainians
can hold on and not lose the russians
can't win if that if that makes sense i
think the other thing to bear in mind of
course
is that whilst i think in most people's
minds there's no doubt that vladimir
putin can
win this battle
how do you win
the war afterwards i the peace i mean
the hatred
in this country for vladimir putin and
the russian invaders
you can't
overstate it and that perhaps
is the ukrainian forces and ukrainian
people's uh most powerful weapon at the
moment harnessing the power of that
emotion
all right alex rossi there in denite pro
thank you very much indeed let's speak
now to uh deputy prime minister and
justice secretary dominic raab thank you
very much indeed for being with us let's
just uh
work out where we are here there's a 40
column of putin's armor just outside
this capital about to lay siege
to kiev a capital of a free democratic
country and the west is
not going to stop him how does that sit
with you
well i'm not sure i'd accept that
characterization first of all we pay
tribute to the heroic defense which bit
of the characterization
which bit do you allow me to explain
that they're there or that the west is
going to stop them can i give the answer
and then you can pick pick up on any
aspect of it
first of all um we do pay tribute to the
heroic defense uh by the ukrainian
forces and their fortitude in the face
of outright aggression from president
putin our viewers the uk is that
putin's mission in ukraine must fail
i don't think it's right to say that
we've done nothing to
stop or curtail what putin is doing i
think if you look at not just the suite
of sanctions on oligarchs
and on banks and on the russian state
but also the impact that the collective
action has had including on the central
bank and on the swift payment system
we've seen the the the biggest fall in
the ruble against the dollar
we've seen the stock market in russia
fall to record lows and the central bank
in russia have to double interest rates
and that is all part of the uh allied uh
if you like the the the uk working with
our international partners efforts to
starve putin's war machine um and it
does have an impact and of course as
you're with correspondents with respect
um
just with respect to um mr rob i didn't
say you were doing nothing to stop him i
said you were not going to stop him he
is going to surround this capital lay
siege to this capital and i asked you
how it sat with you that that could
happen nato has the most powerful air
force in the world
and this is happening in a european
capital in 2022.
well of course
ukraine's not a member of uh nato uh
we've been clear about that in terms of
military participation what we have done
is arm
something like 20 000
ukrainian uh troops we've sent 2 000
anti-tank missiles
we've provided a package of support 100
million pounds
and of course allies and partners have
done
further
support we yesterday announced 40
million additional in humanitarian
assistance so we uh
along with the sanctions suite so and it
has had an impact in the way i described
on putin uh but we know that we putin
will react to this or we fear that putin
will react to this with even more
barbaric tactics uh and that's why we
need to be prepared that this could be a
long haul and we will do everything we
can to achieve our goals of making fruit
insane you seem to be saying
yeah but you seem to be saying that
there's less of a moral case there's
less
of a humanitarian case there's less of
an urgent case because ukraine is not a
member of nato isn't a humanitarian case
and a moral case absolutely
urgent now and does it matter really
that it's not a matter of nature it's
not a member of nato
i think the the the the the
the nato is incredibly relevant in terms
of how we apply
the the principle of collective
self-defense of course it is but what
you're right to say is that morally we
feel a strong duty to do everything we
can to degrade putin's war machine hence
the sanctions i'd describe the impact
they're having also the the efforts
we're taking to support and steal uh the
resolve and the defensive uh
capabilities of the ukrainians uh which
we've done in the way i described on top
of that the humanitarian support and
we're working with our international
partners i think it's been a pretty
clear um and concerted response but your
argument mr rabb your argument seems to
be that you know the argument for not
acting is that it could start another
world war or heaven forbid some sort of
nuclear war well then is what is to stop
president putin going on to attack other
countries just using the same nuclear
threat even countries that are members
of nato
well
the the what is to stop him is th this
is turning into a much much more
perilous uh misadventure for putin and i
think he realized and as your report
made clear it has had a demoralizing
effect on russian forces some of those
young conscripts and it has had uh
the effect of stealing the will of the
ukrainian people and that is how we will
ensure putin fails in ukraine and uh we
are there for the long haul and that's
why i mean again uh with some of these
very brutal tactics that we're seeing
being reported including by sky news
with the harrowing pictures that we will
see in our uh tv screens and in the
newspapers i think we've been very clear
that um those that engage in war crimes
will be held to account and the icc
prosecutors exactly that's absolutely it
there are war crimes happening right now
in this country children are dying
schools are being attacked a
kindergarten has been attacked and the
west is sanctioning russian banks and
kicking russia out of the world cup
yes and but no more than that actually i
mean i i totally accept what you're
saying uh this is the uh barbarous
consequences of such an appalling
aggressive action by president putin
which you're not wishing to stop which
you're not stopping
so forgive me you're interrupting me
every step and you're you're frankly uh
following this on the 24-hour news cycle
which i understand is your liberty to do
what we've said we're going to do is
degrade putin's war machine by starving
it of the finance necessary to operate
and actually if you look at the
short-term consequences uh the the
effects on the ruble effect on the stock
market the doubling of interest rates in
russia it is having the effect that we
want and it is turning into a very very
difficult campaign for putin one which
and we've always said this will be
disastrous for russian uh for putin and
for the russian people but i do think
we'll need to have the stamina to be in
this for the long haul
and that's why making it clear both to
putin but also to commanders in moscow
on the ground in ukraine
that they will be held accountable uh
for any violations of the laws of war
and we've shown the west has shown that
we're willing uh to
to see this through we will not just
look the other way we had radivan
karadic the butcher the balkans end up
in a a british jail cell via the hague
recently uh and that message will go uh
to those commanders on the ground in
moscow as well as back to uh
in ukraine as well as back to moscow and
there will be accountability uh for the
for any crimes that are committed on
ukrainian soil
and for vladimir putin accountability
for vladimir putin um when it comes to
war crimes
well
that is there as well uh he is
ultimately the person in charge uh via
command responsibility and so that is
very much a factor and this ought to
play into his calculations along with
the fact that uh as you as your reporter
uh uh quite rightly said in your your
clip quite rightly said this has not
been the walk in the park that he
expected uh either in terms of uh
ukrainian resistance uh or the
effectiveness of his own tactics so all
of these things will slow down and we
hope uh
encourage change the calculus and get
him to step back uh and again we take
these actions and the uk has done a huge
amount it's been in the vanguard the
prime minister the defense secretary the
foreign secretary
but we do this with our partners and we
are willing to to be in this for the
long haul because i suspect
notwithstanding the initial stuttering
putin will respond uh
and try seek to respond in ever more
heavy-handed ways with the appalling
humanitarian consequences that will have
so what about the idea of enforcing some
sort of no-fly zone to some sort of
humanitarian corridor would you support
trying to enforce a no-fly zone here i
think the defense secretary has already
been clear on that
we're not going to do that because it
will be put us in a position where we
would have to enforce it by uh
in effect shooting down uh russian
planes what we are doing is the measures
that i described to you on sanctions uh
on supporting the ukrainian resistance
and on the accountability piece which i
think will be even more important
and we'll hear more about that in the
days and weeks ahead
how long does british intelligence think
that
um kiev the capital city here can hold
out
well i'm not going to comment directly
on the intelligence we get but
it's very difficult to to say um the
russian initial advance
has been slowed down more than they
expected uh and that is a testament to
the ukrainian uh fortitude and courage
and what we want to do is do everything
we can to delay uh the um the fall of
kiev uh or any of the other major cities
in ukraine and we will continue to look
with our allies at every means of
achieving that so to make sure that
putin fails in ukraine it's critically
important that's our strategic objective
okay well i mean if he i suppose if he
takes um kiev he gets rid of the
government he occupies this country i
suppose he'll consider that he hasn't
failed but are we being a bit mean
spirited
on visas do you think i wonder
a 75 year old woman living
now in a basement in the capital here
who has her son living in london
can she
go and join him
so just on your first point
you know if putin occupies kiev one or
other of the major cities yeah that
doesn't mean this is over because i
think what you'll see
is uh ukrainians uh bedding down for
some form of uh guerrilla um uh
challenge which will take a lot longer
and could well be uh unresolvable from
the point of view of putin's military
objectives and indeed your uh your clip
showed that in terms of the um
the question of visas and ukrainians the
home secretary has
set out the plans for a bespoke
humanitarian
scheme for ukraine allowing up to a
hundred thousand to come here the
dependence of british nationals in the
uk the dependence of uh ukrainians
living in this country and i think
that's the right way to approach and it
follows uh the wider action but how does
the 75 year old woman sorry to interrupt
you but how does the sirens just going
off here but how does a 75 year old
woman living with sirens going off
living in a basement
get to her son who's living in london
can she do that is she able to do that
because i can't see how she does how
does she go to la vie of 11 hours drive
away get a visa and then it just doesn't
make sense
i don't see how she
can get to her son in london
under the current system
well
this is a a consistent feature whenever
we have humanitarian asylum schemes set
up we know that the difficulties on the
ground make it practically very
challenging but we also know that many
will
get out of ukraine those that uh fleeing
through fear
and we need to be ready with our
international partners the europeans uh
others around you who are saying they
can anybody any ukraine can come in any
ukrainian come in for up to three years
or certainly extended family members
other countries are doing why why are we
not doing more
i mean that
we we've set out about the 75 year old
woman is a real one
yes but i can't comment on every uh
potential hypothetical case what i've
just set out is the circumstances and of
course we understand the difficulties of
the practical situation on the ground
that's common to most uh
uh conflict zones of course and we we
recognize that we'll work with all of
our international partners and the un uh
to try and resolve that and to to make
sure that we continue this tradition of
of of offering haven to safe haven to
those fleeing persecution in relation to
the europeans of course they're closer
to ukraine um uh and uh as the ukrainian
ambassador the uk said over the weekend
uh it it will often be the case that
first priority most ukrainians want to
stay in ukraine but if they leave they
want to be as close to their their home
country as possible uh in order to be
able to come back at some point in the
future so i think i don't i think this
woman wants to get to see her son in
london but you know i mean she doesn't
want to go to poland to stay in poland
she wants to go and see her son in
london sorry i don't know if that's the
case but it's clear from what the home
secretary announced yesterday that the
that we would make that uh route
technically open of course it's very
difficult to know how exactly she would
um traverse the country at that age
but but that is the offer the home
secretary has made so actually it
directly addresses the scenario you've
described
okay dominic rob i appreciate you being
with us we're
slightly distracted here by sirens but
uh listen i appreciate your uh talking
to us this morning good to talk to you
okay we've just got some pictures we can
show you now not from this city
but from kharkiv over in the east it
shows a pretty large explosion
and
in fact i know that building that
building is in freedom square in the
center of
kharkiv where we were last week and in
fact you can see some tents
uh in front of it in the ukrainian
colors
and that is that is a stop the war
um kind of permanent demonstration um
and behind it is the local authority
building that is now covered in smoke
you can see there
and
that is a missile attack direct
on
that building in the center
of
kharkiv those pictures
um
just coming in
to sky news
well our political correspondent tamara
cohen joins us live now from
westminster and uh
tomorrow what did you make of what uh
dominic raab had to say
morning mark well you know on the ground
there how urgent the situation is for
the people who are holding out in kiev
but the message very much from the uk
government and indeed from the white
house yesterday is that military support
in the shape of a no-fly zone or other
military support directly to ukraine is
not going to happen uh the white house
made very clear yesterday um that that
would constitute basically a full-scale
war between nato and russia boris
johnson made the same point when he was
asked about it by ukrainians in london
on sunday and so dominic raab said the
best hope we've got is to try and starve
the russian war machine financially that
is the way
the uk feels the best way to make putin
fail while also shoring up the states
around him and we know boris johnson is
traveling today to poland and to see
some british troops in estonia on the
border with russia to see how they are
um propping up that nato eastern flank
but certainly any military supporter in
the shape of a no-fly zone directly to
ukraine is not going to be carried out
and so therefore sanctions and there
have been some very severe sanctions and
the government is planning for more of
those this week we know um they're
planning more uh planning more uh
restrictions on russian banks operating
in london for example we may hear more
about that today
on the big question also of what
ukrainian refugees pouring over the
border to poland at the moment
might be able to do in terms of coming
and reuniting with relatives in london
the government is still yet to set out
exactly how the scheme is going to work
dominic rob
said you know refugee situations occur
in every war but certainly if you
contrast that with what the eu are doing
they have announced they're going to
waive visa rules for ukrainians coming
to eu countries i think there's going to
be a lot of pressure here for the
government to change its policy
okay tamara thank you very much
indeed and the united nations says more
than
half a million people have now fled
ukraine for neighbouring countries
mainly poland
since the start of russia's invasion the
numbers crossing into the countries are
growing
uh well by the hour
281 000 people have entered poland more
than 84 000 have made it to hungary
about 36 000
on the border with moldova more than 32
000
in romania and around 30 000 heading
towards slovakia the un says that the
remainder have been dispersed among
various different countries our europe
correspondent correspondent adam parsons
reports now from
milne
in fact we can't uh
get that report i understand
we can go to aleister bunkel
who i think is in
geneva is he good morning
alastair good morning yeah and a meeting
there liz trust heading there
uh alastair uh
what
can we expect from the talks
well look firstly mark i think probably
uh something along the lines of what you
were you were just saying about the
refugee crisis uh because that is
clearly something that's growing uh by
the day as well uh and europe will need
to come together to work out
a coordinated response to that given
that it is impacting semi borders uh and
so many tens of thousands of ukrainians
now so i'm sure that they will be trying
to seek uh some sort of united uh
humanitarian support for that and some
sort of coordinated asylum response as
well yeah liz trust does come here she's
on her way to the united nations it is a
somewhat a paired down uh gathering
anthony blink and the u.s secretary of
state will address it remotely but he
won't be here in person uh neither will
uh sergey lavrov the russian foreign
minister he says because of the ban on
russian aircraft in european airspace
he's he's not going to be able to come
and so what that does is it removes
perhaps the prospect that some people
were hoping for that the two foreign
ministers of the united states and
russia would be able to get together
behind the scenes and you know who knows
uh maybe find some sort of breakthrough
instead liz trust will come here the
words that the foreign office have
released ahead of it are pretty strong
she will say that russian tanks are
tearing through towns while missiles
barrage homes and hospitals putin is
murdering ukrainians indiscriminately uh
she will say she will also have
bilateral meetings with her canadian
danish
czech counterparts
and i guess they will talk about what
further sanctions can be levied but you
know it is hard it's hard to think what
what more yes okay i'm sure they can go
further but
there has already been a a very united
very coordinated very strong response
from the united nations uh sorry from
the european union countries from
britain from the united states and yet
as we were singing this morning uh
president putin and his military only
step up the assault on ukraine i think
they might look towards belarus as well
and loving sanctions against belarus
that mirror those against russia but
clearly despite
playing a very strong hand with
sanctions it doesn't seem to be stopping
vladimir putin at least in the short
term
no it doesn't uh alastair thank you very
much don't forget every day
this week we'll have a special programme
twice a day on the russian invasion of
ukraine will bring you
everything all the latest about what's
happening here right across the country
as well as correspondents
across the world washington westminster
all over europe that's ukraine invasion
at 1pm
and 7pm all this week
joining me now is the former head of
counter terror at the ministry of
defense major chip chapman good morning
thank you for being with us so we've got
this 40 mile column outside
this capital city what do you expect the
plan to be here
it's about x uh targets have been here
to all the russians are behind their
timeline are irrelevant so what you're
going to see now is the sequencing of
tactical battles for the
uh for the
operational objectives being achieved
and i think we'll see um
kiev being encircled and you'll have an
escalation because an escalation that's
both in target sets and fires more
targets destroyed and you know juicing
bellow will be broken that is that the
targeting will be against legitimacy
proportionality necessity and
distinction in war so they should be
held accountable for that
so we're going to see greater combat
power brought to bear and it's worth
saying that on d plus two the third day
they only had used a third of their
combat power 50 by d plus three and now
they're going to use 75 percent so the
mass that the russians will bring to
bear is the thing which will be crucial
in the next one or two days so the
resistance is remarkable
but ultimately mass may prevail you can
not you can break the will of an enemy
ultimately because it's not just armed
forces that fight wars it's nations that
fight wars
yeah i mean what do you make of the
ukrainian resistance in terms of their
their military they are surprisingly
well equipped you know given the
sort of you know resources that are
coming in here but what have you made of
of how the
ukrainian military are performing
well we talk about fighting power in
three parts uh the moral one they've
been absolutely remarkable but they're
fighting for families country
independence and sovereignty in the way
they thought they've also been very
clever they've been surviving through
movement deception
dispersion and massing when they need to
to
try and chew some of these columns and i
think
interdicting that 40 mile column by
drone strikes or something like that is
absolutely crucial today that you could
have a sort of mittler pass
from the iraq war sort of thing the last
thing is that the um the physical part
of fighting power and they're being well
equipped with sort of the stingers and
ant tank missiles but one of the fears
is that you could have a fourth front i
think and that is a northern grouping
probably out of belarus to try and cut
those supply lines that are coming in
with these uh with these supplies from
nato countries and of course it's worth
saying that there are three russian axes
at the moment the central grouping which
is towards kiev which we've heard a lot
about we've also got these western uh
groupings and southern groupings which
have actually been slightly more
successful because a lot of these
operations are environment operations or
encirclement operations not actually
fighting in the cities and certainly
from american intelligence they're
suggesting at the moment that they're
trying to draw a line between mario paul
uh and the uh in the black sea
up to kharkov and then they will hold
that and that will become de facto
ukrainian territory now that will try to
be negotiated away should there be a
ceasefire but what you have you uh hold
you have generally in military doctrine
yeah you mean de facto russian territory
uh as opposed to ukrainian territory i
mean that that's what he's trying to do
do you think he's trying to get that
slice
down there basically have more of
ukraine so my question would be does to
do that
does he need to
you know
rage on kiev a an onslaught on
kiev and topple the government here
couldn't he just
do it and and hold it and
you know challenge the west to do
anything about it
no no he needs left bank ukraine that's
the part uh to the uh to the east of the
river nipper and he needs kiev for for
two reasons firstly the capital
represents the center of gravity the
source of all strength and secondly and
where he's miscalculated so far is that
he needs to knock over the political
polity now zelensky having stayed in
kiev is absolutely vital because you can
guarantee that he'll have done some
planning on putting a puppet regime in
and if zielinski or a new
or the former government as they would
see it flees to laval he can say this is
the true uh the true government of uh of
ukraine because it is in kiev so kiev is
still vital to hoda and
maintain that polity of zelensky and his
legitimate government because any
government put in by putin would
absolutely be illegitimate
yeah interesting stuff chip uh thank you
very much for being with us this morning
the uk's television watchdog ofcom is
investigating the due impartiality of
programmes on russian state-owned news
channel rt
correspondent sherman freeman powell has
more on this from the newsroom and do we
know what ofcom are going to do i think
labour want them closed down don't they
yes they do well i've come have launched
an investigation and the scale of this
investigation is unprecedented in total
there are 15 investigations currently
ongoing and ofcom said it's going to be
looking into impartiality and whether or
not rt which was formerly called russia
today meets the impartiality standards
that we expect here in the uk now just
to explain that british broadcasting
does allow for politically biased
coverage as long as viewers are also
exposed to alternative views and in
recent days rt been accused of repeating
claims from russian president putin that
russia was actually defending um some of
the regions from ukraine
invasion or from ukraine aggression even
so this move will be looking into this
coverage and whether or not it meets the
standards of ofcom and if not ofcom does
have the power to find or revoke
licences which would be huge if this
happened there could be knock-on effects
for example russia could then block the
public broadcaster bbc from operating in
russia as well as that this
investigation comes after boris johnson
prime minister boris johnson was among
politicians calling for ofcom to
investigate rt and the fact that they
have done so could potentially play into
that narrative that the uk lacks freedom
of expression and that ofcom is being
influenced by british politicians but
despite that we have spoken to the
executive of ofcom she said that this is
an independent decision and explained
why she thought it was necessary
i think the uk's very plural very
diverse news system is a real benefit to
us but at a time like this it's also
incredibly important that services that
broadcast from one particular
perspective are respecting our due
impartiality codes this is not a time
for
well it's never a time for one-sided
propaganda
so ofcom say that they will be wrapping
up this investigation as soon as
possible because they realize the
urgency of this as well as this they're
not alone the european union has also
suggested that some that banning rt and
the news agency sputnik would be a good
idea and separately meta which is a
parent company of facebook has said that
it will also restrict access to rt and
sputnik on its platforms across the
european union as well
okay shiman thank you
the home secretary says the government's
uh absolutely working on the possibility
of helping ukrainian refugees uh go to
the uk or come to the uk the government
has been criticized for ruling out a
blanket visa waiver for those escaping
the conflict i'm joined now by the
director of detention action bella
sankey
thank you very much for being with us uh
so on these visas
is the government uh doing enough
well at the moment it would seem the
government is doing the absolute bare
minimum
um to provide any sort of sanctuary
route for people that are fleeing
ukraine all they've done is slightly
ever so slightly relaxed family
reunification rules
so that people can bring spouses
or children under 18 to the uk even then
there are minimum income requirements
and english language requirements that
on a discretionary basis the home office
might
uh wave so this is leaving people
incredibly uncertain it's leaving people
in limbo not to mention the fact that
elderly parents sisters brothers you
know wider extended family members are
not covered by this scheme and there's
been absolutely no announcement as to
what might be done uh separate to that
to allow ukrainians that don't have
family connections but are in desperate
need and fleeing for their lives to come
to the uk so we're totally out of step
with europe um and the offer we've made
is is meager and poultry
so you would like to see
a system would you similar to the to the
one the eu is introducing which is
i think far more broad is it even or i
think it might even be all ukrainians
could stay up to
three years
so the eu is still going through the
process of deciding on its offer but but
that's what has been
suggested there are so many things that
the uk government could do that would be
better than what's been offered so far
um a visa waiver is one offer a
humanitarian visa could be created which
would allow uh people to come to the uk
after certain um security checks or
whatever have have been made
um we could have a you know a dynamic
evacuation and resettlement scheme there
are lots of different options
open to the home secretary but so far
she's chosen you know to ignore all of
them
i mean the home secretary seems to be
worried about the security implications
of
you know having a more relaxed system
for
ukrainians what what do you make of that
i think it's pretty problematic um that
in her response in the chamber yesterday
um the homestay the home secretary made
so much
of the security point let's not forget
you know that the language of
politicians in this um in this moment is
incredibly important and it's you know
on on the home secretary not to give
rise to unnecessary public concerns
around security these are ordinary
ukrainians that are fleeing uh this
horrendous conflict you know children um
you know completely innocent people
whose lives have been
turned upside down it would be perfectly
possible to do
to devise a system which would allow for
some basic security checks while also
ensuring that people can very swiftly
come to the uk this has been done by the
uk before it could easily be done again
so to try and identify this as some sort
of roadblock to us offering assistance
i think is deeply irresponsible but also
not accurate
right and just finally i mean this could
go on for some
considerable time do you think the
government will eventually
um
you know home secretary says they're
working on it come up with a
slightly more relaxed system
i think it's likely that we might see
some more announcements as this conflict
rages but i think what is so
disappointing is the way in which this
government has had to be dragged kicking
and screaming
even to make the most minor commitment
to immediate family members and how
you know
every single you know further commitment
from here is going to be going to have
to be forced out of this government by
public pressure
um and by uh the statements of the
opposition parties this isn't how it
should be and i think the government has
misjudged this the british public is
much bigger-hearted than i think this
government realizes but
it would it would very much seem that
this government which you know came to
power off the back of the brexit vote uh
which you know was very much um
pushing this line around immigration and
you know restricting immigration to the
uk just can't let go
of that ideology and that's you know
pretty xenophobic sentiment so uh i
think we gotta leave it there we've got
to leave it there i'm so sorry we i'm
sorry to interrupt you we've run out of
time bella but look thank you for being
with us
um
we'll have much more in the next hour
but uh
the war goes on here this is uh a
missile attack in kharkiv the second
biggest city in ukraine that is in a
square called freedom square
we'll have
much more
in the next hour
[Music]